bienvenue pour une nouvelle édition du
Journal de la rédaction tout de suite
les titres du 78 lactu de ce vendredi 20
juin a encour parents d'élèves et
enseignant dans la rue pour demander au
m de revoir sa copie sur les rythmes
scolaires sa proposition d'organisation
ne convient pas Jean-Michel Fourgous UMP
est l'un des plus farouches opposants à
cette réforme il veut assurer un service
minimum eux aussi sont en colère les
salariés de l'hôpital gérontologique et
médico-social de plaisir il conteste le
plan d'économie proposé par la direction
ils viendront s'expliquer en plateau
tout à l'heure et puis comme chaque
vendredi retour sur les principales
actualités de la semaine ouverture du
bac 2014 contestation à la SNCF ou
encore vous revivrez le début du Mondial
de football à noter que nous parlerons
aussi dans ce journal de la nouvelle
carte des communes prioritaires dans le
cadre de la politique de la ville
l'image du jour c'est à Versailles et le
chantier du Solar Decathlon qui a débuté
c'est sur le site des matelots que les
20 équipes représentant 16 nationalités
différentes montent depuis lundi leur
prototype de maison solaire pour cette
compétition internationale qui a lieu
tous les 2 ans étudiants architectes et
ingénieurs ont exactement 11 jours pour
parachever leurs œuvres pour les aider
des grues et des spécialistes du
bâtiment sont venus en renfort vendredi
27 juin inauguration officielle de ces
habitations futuristes pour que tout
soit opérationnel le jour J les équipes
travaillent également la nuit le
chantier on a commencé lundi dernier
c'est déjà le 5e jour il me semble on en
a 10 on est sur un système de 38 trois
équipes on tourne moi je suis du matin
il y en a qui sont de la nuit c'est un
peu difficile pour la nuit par qu'il
fait moins moins chaud puis ils ont du
mal à dormir on dort pas beaucoup il y
en a qui dort même
plus donc voilà forcément ça un projet
ambitieux donc il y a pas mal de choses
à faire à la dernière à la dernière
minute mais voilà on est motivé on est
soudé donc on fait on fera en sorte de
rendre la maison dans les temps le
gouvernement a dévoilé la nouvelle carte
des communes et quartiers prioritaires
dans le cadre de la politique de la
ville dans les ivelines seul morpa
intègre ce dispositif alors que Montini
le Bretonneux saincir l'école ou encore
manilé Amot en sortte être classé
commune prioritaire permet de recevoir
des dotations financières
supplémentaires mais aussi des renforts
humains pour l'encadrement des élèves
par exemple on écoute le maire de
maniléamoau qui s'attendait à avoir
cette aide s'arrêtter elle aura duré une
vingtaine d'années a aura permis de
changer durablement le visage du
quartier du Buisson on s'y attendait
euh maintenant aujourd'hui on travaille
surtout sur l'accompagnement de la
sortie et j'ai alerté depuis plusieurs
mois déjà euh madame la sous-préfite à
la ville justement sur le principe d'une
d'une sortie en douceur euh pour surtout
ne pas mettre en péril
euh tous les toutes les avancées qu'on a
pu avoir ces dernières années le manque
à gagner est difficile à estimer puisque
si on a une continuité euh dans le droit
commun euh c'est-à-dire une continuité
sur des subventionnements par
différentes autres collectivités pour la
continuité de certains de nos
dispositifs dans ce cas-là n'aura pas
énormément de perte
à éoncour nous en avons déjà parlé cette
semaine les parents d'élèves et les
directeurs d'écoes s'oppose aux
propositions du maire sur les rythmes
scolaires le maire a déjà revu sa copie
mais cela n'a pas suffi à calmer le
mouvement manifestation vient de se
tenir jeudi soir et d'autres ne sont pas
à exclure Anthony R et Jonathan
villman 15 minutes le midi 30 en fin de
journée c'est la nouvelle proposition du
maire UMP d'élancour Jean-Michel
Fourgous pour les temps d'activité
périscolaire à la rentrée prochaine une
répartition de ces tap dont ne veut pas
cette centaine de parents d'élèves le
problème c'est que sur 15 minutes il est
pas possible d'avoir une activité le
temps de sortir les affaires le temps de
ranger il y aura rien et le soir pareil
en 30 minutes je vois pas ce qu'on peut
faire donc le tout c'est d'avoir une
activité de 45 minutes sur laquelle on
puisse effectiv avoir une activité
efficace plutôt que sur des découpages
qui r à rien on a aussi du mal aussi à
percevoir si effectivement il va y avoir
place donc une animation il y aura
effectivement s'il y aura des des un
recrutement aussi d'animateurs donc
voilà si c'est pour faire de la garderie
moi non non ça m'intéresse pas du tout
l'application des nouveaux rythmes
scolaires à H encour nécessiterait le
recrutement d'une centaine de personnes
supplémentaire l'équipe municipale
privilégierait donc un recours au
professeurs pour encadrer ces tap
résultat cela coûterait deux fois plus
cher que des animateurs on peut faire
des soit des des cours de jeu d'échec
puisque sa qu'on a la fédération d'chec
ici et que déjà les enfants sont formés
ou bien jouer avec des contenus
numériques des contenus numériques
riches innovants avec surtout avec leur
tablette ou bien faire des des cours
d'anglais bien ou bien dans certains cas
en fait prolonger le cours du prof si
les profs bien sûr sont sont intéressés
cette application des nouveaux rythmes
scolaires coûterait à la ville
d'élencour environ 500000 € pour
tamponner cette nouvelle dépense la
commune visage de créer un nouvel
impôt et pendant que le maire d'élencour
entend obtenir l'implication des
enseignants pour ces tap à montinier le
Bretonneau on recrute des animateurs un
forum vient de se tenir les candidats ne
manquaient pas en reconversion
professionnelle ou déjà animateurs
souhaitant renforcer leurs horaires et
donc leurs salaires ils étaient une
trentaine au total pour 28 postes des
formations seront dispensées à ce
n'ayant pas toutes les qualifications
requises une nouvelle présidente pour la
FCPE des Yvelines la Fédération des
conseils de parents d'élèves des des
écoles publiques vient de désigner
Valérie Troma à sa tête dans le
département pour un mandat de 1 an elle
réaffirme les valeurs qu'elle entend
défendre laïcité et gratuité notamment
Valérie Troma qui sera l'invité du 78
lactu le 1er juillet il a la formation
des parents la formation des parents est
importante on se rend compte que les les
conseils d'école sont tout sauf
démocratiques et sans formation les
parents ont du mal à trouver leur place
pour ouvrir un dialogue et et les débats
en fait nécessaires pour faire évoluer
l'école là ce qui se passe au niveau du
conseil départemental on a des
difficultés à recruter des
administrateurs on a 21 postes de prévus
au niveau de nos statuts mais çaulement
15 de pourvus donc on a ce travail là
aussi à faire sur le terrain pour pour
insiter les les parents
à venir en fait postuler sur les PO
d'administrateurs au CDPE c'est
important parce que sans la présence
d'administrateurs en nombre suffisant on
a du mal à être présent sur les
différentes réunions où on siège
notamment sur les instances mais
également auprès des des partenaires et
ce qui nous permet aussi d'atttoir nos
valeurs et de faire rayonner la FCPE et
et nos
actions et il s'agissait bien de Valérie
Troma cette nouvelle présidente de la
FCP on reste dans le domaine de
l'éducation avec l'appel lancé cette
semaine sur notre antenne par
l'association aFS Vivre Sans Frontières
une association qui permet dans une
cinquantaine de pays à des jeunes de
s'installer pendant une année dans des
familles d'accueil des jeunes qui
peuvent ainsi vivre vivre en immersion
totale dans la culture du pays tout en
suivant leur scolarité AF FS manque de
famille justement une quinzaine pour le
mois de septembre le témoignage de la
responsable locale qui était l'invité du
journal jeudi soir tout le monde peut
être famille d'accueil dans le sens où
il ne faut pas nécessairirement avoir
des enfants de l'âge de l'accueilli des
jeunes enfants des jeunes retraités sans
enfant des familles recomposées des
familles parents célibataire ou voilà
donc en fait on étud remarqué qu'il faut
tout de même que les familles soient
comprennent que les les jeunes qui
viennent ne sont pas là ni pour
regardarder les enfants ni pour faire
voà les jeunes voilà de ce côté là c'est
vraiment c'est c'est vraiment des jeunes
qui doivent ils ont l'obligation de
suivre une scolarité et c'est très
important que les familles comprennent
ça et suivent une scolarité et c'est
c'est ce c'est aussi cette espèce de de
petit grain de culture l'école le lycée
qui est pas facile pour les gens qui
arrivent le lycée français est quand
même assez dur et c'est par ça qu'il
doivent passer aussi donc c'est
compliqué donc il faut les soutenir
aussi les jeunes dans cette expérience
là en fait les jeunes donc sont
accueillis bénévolement par des familles
euh et il ils ont l'obligation d'aller
au lycée et donc ils vivent vraiment la
vie d'un lycéen français euh et donc ils
apprennent en fait la langue parce que
certains arrivent en France sans parler
un petit bot de français donc ils
apprennent la langue ils apprennent la
culture et ils apprennent surtout la
culture familiale euh c'est-à-dire ben
comment on fait à manger comment on
éduque ses enfants comment on fait son
lit dans la famille où ils sonont nos
familles sont entièrement bénévoles donc
elles s'impliquent très très fort et
c'est pour pour ça qu'on les soutient
pour vraiment les aider à réussir cette
expérience d'unre d'un autre côté nous
offrons la carte imaginaire pour les
enfants qui en ont besoin nous
remboursons la carte imaginaire et la
cantine pour les familles qui le veulent
aussi donc il y a quand même une petite
une petite participation de
l'association le baccalauréat va bientôt
connaître son épilogue après une semaine
d'épreuves les résultats seront dévoilés
le 4 juillet cette année encore le
stress a été important pour de nombreux
lycéens et parmi les 10000 candidats
evvelinois nous avons suivi cette Ann
Coline élève de terminal ES retour sur
son arrivée dans la salle d'examen lors
de l'épreuve de philosophie lundi
dernier Mathilde
capberne lycée hoch pas de panique dans
cet établissement versaillais à 8h aucun
candidat ne manquait à l'appel les
proviseurs avaient reçu des consignes
stricts du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale sur l'accueil effectivement
des élèves qui arriveraient
éventuellement en retard les accueillir
pendant 1 heure après la la distribution
des des sujets et de leur accorder un
temps équivalent à leur
retard dans la mesure où le retard éta
justifié effectivement par les problèmes
de la SNCF ici près de 400 élèves se
sont penchés sur l'épreuve de
philosophie une épreuve plus ou moins
redoutée bah non j'étais pas trop
stressé parce que j'avais bien révisé
pendant la semaine de révision j'étais
assez confiant de moi n on est plus
stressé pour les matières scientifiques
vu qu'on est en S donc la philo non moi
j'ai plutôt l'habitude de pas forcément
beaucoup réussir en philosophie donc je
me disais qu'au pire j'avais une
mauvaise note et j'avais l'habitude très
très stressé mais j'ai pris un
médicament et après ça allit mieux pas
spécialement parce que je pense que
c'est aussi un travail qui se fait sur
toute l'année suffit-il d'avoir le choix
pour être libre ou pourquoi chercher à
se connaître deux sujets de dissertation
pour l'épreuve de philosophie dé
terminales en économie et sociale pas de
quoi effrayer Coline elle choisit
l'étude de texte celui de Anna arent une
fois devir ma copie déjà j'ai choisi
plutôt vite les deux dissertations m'p
Seris pas tellement donc j'ai choisi
l'étude l'étude de texte et je pensais
que j'aurais du mal à rentrer dedans et
au final je l'ai lu deux ou trois fois
et après ça allait beaucoup mieux j'ai
passé 1 He3 sur mon brouillon et donc là
après je suis sortie en avance c'est pas
forcément ce qu'il faut faire mais je
suis plutôt contente de moi
fait partie des meilleurs établissements
de l'île-de-fance filière S et ES sont
présenté l'année dernière le lycée
affiché plus de 99 % de réussite alors
l'année dernière les résultats h ont été
ont été excellents
9 19 entre 99 et 99 et5i % la
particularité de hoch c'est que
effectivement on a on accueille de de
très très bons élèves à l'entrée en
seconde et on garde la totalité de nos
élèves en seconde première terminale
Coline et ses camarades doivent encore
se concentrer sur la suite des épreuves
au programme mardi histoire et
géographie en tout plus de 17000
candidats se présentent au baccalauréat
dans le
département rendez-vous donc le 4
juillet pour les résultats et le stress
a été d' autant plus grand cette année
pour certains étudiants que les employés
de la SNCF étaient en grève un conflit
qui commence à s'essouffler mais qui
reste pénalisant pour les usagers alors
que les débats autour de la réforme
ferroviaire s'ouvrait à l'Assemblée
certains cheminaux sont venus
interpeller le député socialiste
Jean-Philippe met à sa permanence à
trrappe sa réponse à ce mouvement
c'était mardi soir dans le 78 politique
sur
TVfil je ne comprends pas la réaction là
de ces militants puisque le projet de
loi a été lorsqu'il a été élaboré il y a
eu vraiment une concertation étroite
étroite avec en particulier la CGT qui a
été à tous les stades de la confection
de ce projet de loi a été informé bien
ce projet de loi d'une certaine façon va
dans la direction de ce que souhaitait
la CGT c'est-à-dire une réunification
vous savez de la de RFF et de la SNCF il
y aura trois établissements publics
industriels et commerciaux un de tête et
deux la SNCF mobilité et réseau qui
seront chapautés par cette cet
établissement public il ne s'agit it pas
de remettre en cause le statut des des
cheminau ils ont tort de faire grève oui
non non je ne dirais pas qu'ils ont tort
de faire grève parce que la la grève est
un droit constitutionnel moi je les
respecte profondément SEM av oui tout à
fait il faut parler de ce qu'il y a dans
le projet de loi et ne pas être dans
dans dans des choses qui ne sont pas
dans le projet de loi autre conflit
social celui qui oppose les agents de
l'hôpital plaisir grigon à leur
direction l'établissement a dévoilé un
plan d'économie elle doit réduire son
déficit de moitié d'unli4 700000 € une
intersyndicale a organisé plusieurs
manifestations depuis cette annonce ses
représentants vont s'expliquer dans un
instant en plateau mais on écoute déjà
l'une de ses salariés qui s'exprimait
lors de la dernière mobilisation
jeudi mauvaise santé à ce point-là non
mais bon on se doutait qu'il y avait des
problèmes oui de toute façon tous les
hôpitaux généraux ont des problèmes on
vous demande de faire de la rentabilité
aujourd'hui dans un dans un hôpital quoi
voilà rien que ce mot déjà vous avez
tout compris faire de la rentabilité moi
t les matin on me demande alors taux
d'occupation il a combien je pense qu'il
y a autre chose à gérer
avant Corine le pape pour la CGT
Catherine sajo pour Force ouvrière et
Édouard Caron pour su bonsoir à tous les
trois bienvenue en plateau vous
représentez cette intersyndicale qui
mobilise les les salariés on vient
d'entendre une salariée justement elle
parle de rentabilité il ne serait plus
question de santé publique dans votre
établissement c'est ce que vous
ressentez également oui oui mais c'est
c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui d'ailleurs le
notre trac de ce matin en dit long
puisque le titre c'est il ne pense qu'au
sous nous ne pensons qu'au soin sur
votre activité au quotidien vous le
ressentez vous aussi dans vos différents
services on vous demande de faire
rentabilité absolument nous en tant
quefin en tant que soignant on ne peut
pas raisonner avec une calculatrice dans
la tête quoi nous sommes soignants avant
tout nous nous nous avons des patients
dans nos lits on ne peut pas raisonner
comme ça enfin bon l'hôpital public n'a
jamais été là pour faire de bénéfice
pour économiser 700000 € puisque c'est
ce qui est demandé il faut réduire donc
ce déficit de moitié la direction
devrait geler le nombre de lits en
rééducation en gerériatrie ça va
signifier quoi pour les patients 20 lit
de de soins de suite gériatrique et 10
lit de médecine physique et de
réadaptation orthopédique ce que ça va
générer pour les patients c'est que pour
les surtout pour les les hôpitaux
environnants où l'établissement de
l'hôpital plaisir Grignon est une
filière d'aval ce qui permet à surtout
l'établissement un établissement comme
mot de ne pas garder leurs malades trop
longtemps dans les lits et ce qui fait
que aujourd'hui si les lits
disparaissent ou sont gelés parce qu'on
parle pas de fermeture on parle de gel
si les lits sont gelés sur l' GMS ils
auront plus de difficultés pour écouler
leurs patients des lit sur les hôpitaux
généraux comme M surtout surtout mot et
y compris nous on a un service de
médecine aigu hein qui nous sert de
filière d'aval où il est demandé en
règle générale dans ses services de
médecine aigu que le patient reste entre
3 et 5 jours maximum heureusement qu'on
avit des une filière de soins de suite
gériatrique pour nous permettre de
pouvoir faire sortir rapidement les les
patients qui qui qui qui sont en phase
aigu Corine le PAP juste pour les
salariés ça veut dire aussi des postes
supprimés c'est ça tout à fait et c'est
justement la grande inquiétude parce que
on nous annonce actuellement là trois
suppressions de poste enfin TR non
renouvellement de contrat en fin juin et
tris non renouvellement de contrat en
fin juillet mais bon pour nous c'est ça
équivut à des licenciements et six
paires de postes parce que la direction
ne veut pas parler de suppression de
postees c'est ce qu'on vous a répondu he
il y a pas de suppression de postees ce
sont des CDD et la direction dit que
c'était même encore un peu prématuré que
de vous inquiéter vous répondez quoi
c'est c'est ce qui oui c'est c'est ce
qui nous disent suppression de poste si
c'est des suppressions de poste c'est
des CDD c'est des des gens qui sont sur
le terrain donc s'il sont sur sur le
terrain c'est que il y a vraiment un un
réel besoin de de de de de ces gens-là
donc suppression de poste nous a SII on
reste sur ce mot-l automatiquement
minimum 11 on part sur les les chiffres
alors ce sont pas des chiffres erronés
puisque ils nous ont été communiqués par
notre direction il y a 11 CDD qui seront
pas renouvelés donc pour nous ce sont 11
postes supprimés la demande aujourd'hui
c'est une intervention financière de
l'ARS l'agence régionale de santé vous
voulez se mettre la main à la poche pour
qu' tiennne ses engagements par av
engagement il y avait un engagement qui
avait été pr mais de manière orale c'est
c'est c'est que du verbal et aujourd'hui
on aimerait que il y a aucun écrit ce
qui fait que aujourd'hui ça notre
déficit il est d'unlion4 si la RS tient
ses engagements c'est-à-dire de financer
ses 700000 € aujourd'hui on passe sous
la barre des 3 % et on n pas besoin de
faermer de lit par qu' a une obligation
légale les établissements publics de
santé peuvent peuvent pas être à plus de
3 % de déficit c'est ça oui si sinon on
se retrouve sous tutelle sous tutelle
justement quand on vous dit qu'il faut
faire des des économies des concessions
vous êtes prêt à en faire est-ce que
vous êtes prêt à faire des
concessions les concessions oui mais pas
à n'importe quel prix et pas au
détriment de la prise en charge de nos
résidents parce que actuellement on sait
très bien qu'automatiquement s'il y a
des diminutions de postes ou autre il y
aura forcément des impacts sur la prise
en charge et même sur la le fait de pas
pouvoir garder certaines personnes sur
du SSR gériatrique fait que bon on peut
se poser la question de savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on va en faire que vont-ils devenir
vous avez organisé des débrayages tout
au long de de la semaine ces derniers
jours vous bloqueiez un temps pour pour
aller exprimer votre votre
mécontentement on a vu encore quelques
images de de jeudi vous allez poursuivre
ce mouvement vous vous arrêtez
aujourd'hui et vous allez procéder
différemment après on va procéder
différemment aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il
y a un dernier piquet de greffe cet
après-midi de 14h à 15h et ensuite on on
va réfléchir à d'autres actions durant
l'été mais on pense à un temps fort au
mois de septembre où puisqu'il y a
d'autres menaces qui nous qui pèsent sur
l'établissement sur euh sur un autre
secteur d'activité hein qu'on appelle
anciennement les maisons de retraite
donc aujourd'hui on appelle ça des
épanes donc on ouais on sent
qu'aujourd'hui il y a aussi une volonté
euh de peut-être de fermer des lits
d'pades puisqu'on aurait pas les moyens
financiers de restructurer le le nombre
de lit despades qu'on a aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on a on a un volume de 284
personnes il semblerait que on irait
vers la disparition de de plus d'une
centaine de de p donc d'autres actions
d'autres mobilisations à la rentrée sont
prévu tout à fait et puis parce que
justement par rapport ce que vient de
dire mon collègue on sait très bien que
la politique actuellement au niveau des
épades est plus de faire sortir du giron
du public la prise en charge de ces
personnes merci à vous trois Mobilation
aimit conclure par un dernier mot r où
on se demande le devenir de la prise en
charge des personnes âgées avec les
moyens qu'on nous alloue aujourd'hui
merci à vous trois mobilisation qui se
pour poursuivra donc à plaisir avec ce
mot d'ordre non à l'austérité dans les
aostau c'était sur vos différents
tractes merci à vousci dans le domaine
de la santé toujours vient de se tenir
la journée mondial du don du sang le
nombre de prélèvements a été plutôt bon
notamment sur l'île-defance pendant que
ces invités quittent le plateau merci
cela ne doit pas faire oublier que
pendant l'été la solidarité ne peut pas
s'arrêter en matière de don du sang donc
le docteur Denis pages un des
responsables de l'établissement français
du don du sang s'exprime à ce sujet on
l'écoute pour l'ensemble de
l'île-de-fance c'est positif h puisque
nous avons prélevé plus de donneurs que
prévu nous avions prévu euh dans
prélever 1330 on l'a fait 1337 euh comp
tenu de ce que ça représente il faut
savoir que pour une base comme
Versailles par exemple 1337 en moyenne
ce qu'on réalise sur une semaine de 6
jours donc c'est un excellent résultat
compte tenu des excellents résultat de
du 14 juin on est à peu près tranquille
jusque allez au 10 12 août on est en
état de stock on n pas trop mal et euh
chaque année et c'est pas à cause des
jmds c'est à cause des vacances d'été là
on commence à être un petit peu en
difficulté et donc moi si j'ai un
conseil une recommandation à donner au
donneur c'est commencer à donner à
partir de la 2uxè quinzaine de juillet
la première quinzaine d'août et nous ça
nous régulera d'autant que les services
hospitaliers qui consomme du sang et
bien certains qui ferment en août parce
qu'ils ont passé le personnel pour le
maintenir avec un niveau de sécurité et
d'efficacité correcte donc en fait venez
donner à partir de du 10 juillet comme
si c'était les 14 juin mais le 10
juillet nous sommes vendredi si vous
nous suivez en direct et ce soir la
France va affronter la Suisse pour son
2e match du premier tour du Mondial 2014
de football les supporters sont prêts
dans une certaine euphorie après la
large victoire sur le Honduras il y a
quelques jours pour se plonger dans
l'ambiance avant ce match France- Suisse
retour sur la rencontre face au Honduras
depuis boisarcy qui proposait des écrans
géants pour l'occasion c'est tous les 4
ans donc effectivement l'abri blues
pouvait pas louper ce rendez-vous on
sait pas combien il y aura de personne
mais en tout cas ce dont je suis sûr
c'est que la France va gagner justement
un petit pronostic 3-0 un supporteur
bien inspiré avant le coup d'envoi de la
rencontre Fran onuras dimanche soir
s'ils étaient nombreux à croire en la
victoire de la France ils étaient en
revanche un peu moins àprès dire un tel
dénouement ici à boisarc l'abri blues la
salle de spectacle retransmettait le
premier match des Bleu et c'est ensemble
que les spectateurs ont vécu l'ouverture
du
score une équipe de France
volontaire et qui joue un football
plaisant à voir bien engagé et qu'il
continue comme ça c'est parfait très bon
état d'esprit ils auraient pu mettre au
moins de buts pense facilement et on a
pas eu de chance et j'espère qu'en deè
mi-temps il vont le ils vont quand même
leur mettre au moins de autres buts un
veu exaucé par Karim
Benzema 3-0 score final sur le fond
comme sur la forme cette équipe de
France version Didier deschan séduit et
semble réconcilier avec son public on
est content que l'équipe de France est
gagné et bien entamé sa coupe du
mondeip pas trop mal pas trop mal contre
une équipe qui était vachement du à
jouer quand même le PU devrait donc
venir encore en masse lors des deux
prochaines retransmissions programmées
ici à laab blous de boisarc c'est un
grand événement pour nous parce que
c'est le début de la Coupe du Monde
c'est la France la France qui est en
pleine dynamique j'ai l'impression et on
avait envie nous de transmettre ce
dynamisme la population arcisienne dans
un endroit qui est
plutôt très identitaire pour boisarcis
très connu c'est l'abri BL c'est là on
fait les concerts c'est là où la
jeunesse se retrouve c'était vraiment
tout trouvé justement pour qu'on
retransmette les matches de l'équipe de
France ici
on se retrouve lundi pour un nouveau
journal en espérant bien évidemment la
nouvelle victoire de la France face à la
Suisse profitez bien de votre weekend
nous fêterons la musique demain pour le
premier jour de l'été édition spéciale
du 78 weekend à suivre sur notre antenne
à partir de ce vendredi soir pour tout
connaître de la programmation près de
chez vous ce sera avec Catherine zulato
à
lundi